Okay, let's continue our coverage of public
health of infectious disease and the incompetence
of this administration in the context of the
now possible Corona virus pandemic headlines
have been floating around that Donald Trump
fired the U S pandemic response team.
This sounds crazy. Why would any president
fire the pandemic response team? Is this really
true? And the answer is yes, it is. It is
true. The Trump administration fired the U
S pandemic response team in 2018 to cut costs.
This started circulating after Judd Legan,
who runs the popular information newsletter
tweeted quote with the Corona virus killing
thousands and threatening to tank the global
economy. I feel like more people should be
talking about the fact that Trump fired the
entire pandemic response team two years ago
and then didn't replace them. Trump also cut
funding for the CDC, forcing the CDC to cancel
its efforts to help countries prevent infectious
disease threats from becoming epidemics in
39 of 49 countries in 2018 among the countries
abandoned China. And Judd goes on to say,
this isn't about, this isn't just about accountability,
it's about drawing attention to these structural
problems in the U S response effort before
things get worse.
We are seeing this front and center here in
the United States. We are seeing front and
center how stuff that is just politics very
quickly becomes life and death and much more
than mere political posturing and a positioning.
White house officials tasked with directing
national responses to pandemics were fired
in the spring of 2018 that's true. And as
Snopes points out, rear Admiral Timothy Ziemer
abruptly departed from his post leading the
global health security team on the national
security council in May, 2018 amid a reorganization
of the council by then national security advisor,
John Bolton Zimmer's team was disbanded. Tom
Bossert, who was the Washington post reported
had called for a comprehensive biodefense
strategy against pandemics and biological
attacks had been fired one month prior. If
it weren't tragic life and death, it would
be indistinguishable from some kind of weird
comedy or satirical skit, but it's all real.
It's true that the Trump administration cut
the executive branch team responsible for
coordinating responses to pandemics.
Did he cut CDC funding? Yes, he did. 2018
reports say that funding for the CDCs global
disease outbreak prevention efforts were cut
by 80% which includes the CDCs effort in China.
The central point, the focus of Corona virus
today when we've been sounding the alarm for
three years now saying this man is a danger
to the country. That was not a metaphor that
was not hyperbolic. This was simply the sober
assessment of the situation. The way to observe
this administration is to try to ignore the
propaganda videos and look only at what they
do right? The big videos of Trump looking
tough and heroic in China or India rather
or wherever it is that he's traveling to.
Don't look at how they present themselves,
watch what they do, and you will very quickly
understand the incompetent reality of what
is taking place here. We had enough to worry
about economically before Corona virus, we
had enough to worry about socially the fabric
of politics and discourse in the United States
geo.
Politically, we had more than enough to worry
about with Donald Trump. We had more than
enough to worry about with Donald Trump without
a growing outbreak of coronavirus, which medical
experts have said Trump's response to so far
has been, and I quote incoherent now. We also
have that to worry about as well and we have
morons running the response. When I say we'll
be lucky to get out of this alive I, that's
literally the case for millions and millions
of people. If this continues to grow and we
need competent people, this isn't about do
we build a wall or not. Okay. This is not
about from claiming that he's building the
wall when he's not. We're talking about a
life and death situation potentially for millions
of people and we have uh, arguably the least
competent people in charge. Absolutely concerning.
Um, I, you know, you all know that from that
we've been reporting on coronavirus for months
and from the beginning I said I am not going
to become more alarmist about this than the
facts actually suggest. And early on when
you are starting to see very alarmist reporting
in some places we were sober and our assessment
of what was going on, contextualizing Corona
virus, looking at SARS, looking at influenza,
so on and so forth. We are seeing growing
numbers that are caused for more concern.
But the real red alert now is the incompetence
of the people we have in charge. And the fact
that a lot of the competition
people have been fired. Let me know where
your head fat so to speak on coronavirus.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more right after this